[Music]
he
oh
[Music]
he
oh
[Music]
this is Reggie from
Nintendo before we begin we want to
extend our condolences to all the
victims of the two tragic events in
Orlando our thoughts are with their
families and their
communities and this includes Christina
Grimmy who was killed in the earlier
incident and was scheduled to visit us
here at our E3 Booth this week
at Nintendo we try to make our fans
smile but this week at E3 we'll also be
shedding a few
tears please join me in a moment of
[Music]
silence
if you've been a fan of Nintendo over
the years you'll know that the Nintendo
experience is different at every
E3 we always look for the best way to
introduce our most important
content and this year is no different
and that's why we're coming to you
directly from our show booth on the set
of Nintendo Treehouse live on the other
side of the wall behind me the finishing
touches are being made before we open it
up to thousands of Industry insiders in
just a couple of
hours that space will immerse visitors
in the world of a single game the newest
entry and The Legend of Zelda
franchise what's in store is an entirely
new format for a Zelda
game three three decades ago the first
Zelda game changed the way millions of
people thought about video games and
this week you'll discover a game that
could change that thinking again here's
the first look at what
awaits open your
[Music]
eyes
[Applause]
[Music]
here
open your
eyes wake up
[Music]
link
[Applause]
[Music]
a
[Applause]
[Music]
la
[Applause]
[Music]
oh
The Legend of Zelda breath of the wild
introduces you to a Hyrule that is truly
seamless we simply moving from one place
to another begins to create what may be
the adventure of a
lifetime and not only is this new world
vast but it feels alive it teams with
Adventure throughout Link's Quest Hyrule
will be a resource an ally an enemy and
always a place for Discovery and
wonder this is easily one of the biggest
experiences ever created by Nintendo and
today you're going to get a close-up
look the portion of the game we're
highlighting at E3 a wide ranging
Plateau may seem huge in fact no one
here this week will be able to explore
all of it but even then that Plateau is
only a tiny fraction of the full game
map we'll be devoting almost this full
first day of Nintendo Treehouse live
coverage to just this one
environment then in the future you'll
learn more about the story the
characters and the ways in which the
boundaries of all previous Zelda titles
are being
broken but in the end full understanding
and full immersion will only come when
you experience it for yourself
however before we show you this biggest
adventure for Wii U and NX we're going
to show you the biggest new adventure
coming up for Nintendo
3DS as you've heard there are two new
core Pokemon titles on the way on
November
18th Pokemon Sun and Pokemon
Moon as always you'll pick which new
starter Pokemon to partner with but
which one to choose exactly what kind of
battling awaits you and what does the
new alola region have in store for
players well we figured there was no one
better equipped to answer those
questions than the two key developers of
the game itself producer Jun matsuda and
director shuru omore of
gamefree so before we devote the rest of
the day to The Legend of Zelda I'm going
to turn it over to the Treehouse team
along with Mr Mr matsuda and Mr omore to
show you what it's like to start as a
Pokemon trainer in the first ever live
gameplay demonstration of Pokemon Sun
and Pokemon Moon so let's jump in take
it away Sam and
Terry thanks Reggie and thanks to
everyone watching for tuning in and
joining us for another Nintendo
Treehouse live at E3 we're really
excited to get started so as uh Reggie
mentioned I'm Sam from Nintendo and
joining me up here I've got Terry from
Nintendo and my colleague David from
tpci and we've also got our very special
guests uh masaan and omori son from Game
Freak who are joining us to chat about
Pokemon Sun and Pokemon moon now uh
Pokemon fans already know that you guys
have a very long history of working with
the Pokemon franchise but could you tell
our viewers a little bit more about what
you guys are doing specifically with
Pokemon Sun and Pokemon
Moon
so this is the 20th anniversary of
Pokemon as I think many of you know and
when thinking about the future of
Pokemon uh I've decided that I would be
the producer uh on this title and also
and pass over the uh director role over
to Shi here for Pokemon Sun and
Moon so I'm sharo Mori from game freak
and I was the director on this game
overseeing the entire development of it
well thank you so much for joining us
today I know you brought some art assets
that we can take a look at to introduce
folks to the Pokemon Moon Pokemon Sun
collection but first we've actually got
some video footage that you brought for
us so uh folks watching if you sit tight
we're actually going to get that queued
up for you so you can take a
[Music]
look
[Applause]
[Music]
yeah
all right so there's a lot for us to
talk about just from the footage there
uh the first thing I'd like to actually
uh ask you is uh if you could tell us a
little bit more about the background of
why you went with sun and moon as the
titles for these
games
[Music]
so there's a variety of meanings behind
the titles but one of the main things is
that for example for here on Earth
obviously the sun uh really is the
source of life on this planet and in the
same way in the Pokémon world it's also
a source of life on the planet and the
moon also affects all of our lives here
as well with this game we really wanted
to express this kind of feeling of a
region really teaming with life so we
felt that sun and moon would be an
appropriate title for the games I think
especially thinking about these big
Elemental forces Sun and the Moon uh we
also need to talk about those
legendaries that are on the packaging
because I think folks are going to
really want to hear a little bit more
about uh what they can expect from those
Pokemon
[Music]
so in the games the Legends say that Sol
Galo and uh lunala are the emissaries of
the Sun and the Moon respectively uh and
they these two legendary Pokemon
actually they kind of play a unique role
they tie into the story in a unique way
that we really haven't done with pairs
of legendary Pokémon before so I think
fans would be really excited about it I
think there a really interesting
spiritual element that we get in these
games I won't talk about that too much
yet because I know we're saving some
surprises but on the subject of
legendaries I know um you recently had
an event in Taiwan where you revealed
some news about another Legendary
Pokémon folks remember from XY and what
they might expect from that Pokemon in
these games we can maybe talk about that
a little bit
too
so zygard the Pokemon that one of the
Legendary Pokemons that appeared in
originally X Y just Rec showed off their
uh the 10% form and complete form uh in
the games and these Pokemon will or
these forms will appear in Pokemon Sun
and Moon kind of a in a special way that
I think people will be excited about
they look so cool and and actually here
since we're looking a little bit of the
Ala region in the background uh this is
probably a good chance to talk maybe in
a little bit more detail tell about the
alola region and what players can maybe
expect
there
uh so the alola region as you can see is
made of these four Islands it has a a
man-made Island as well um but it's
really uh this region that's just like a
teaming with life and that's actually
behind the the name of the region itself
we have this uh meaning of kind of a uh
region over like a miraculous region
overflowing with this life force that
can support all this different uh life
and um yeah yeah I think it's really
interesting since it's not connected to
any of the other regions you've got this
really interesting area of isolation and
we're seeing all these Pokémon that
nobody's ever run into before and it's
almost kind of feels like the Galapagos
Islands where you've got this really
interesting remote area where all these
other creatures are are popping up and
you've got new Pokemon and a really cool
environment as well to
explore yeah I think people be surprised
some cool things to see in the there are
I've been playing at work and I'm very
excited get a look at it
and actually since we're talking about
new Pokémon um is there anything more
that you can tell our viewers about the
three starters that they'll be choosing
from in this
[Music]
game
so of course they're all very cute but
uh one of the things they really focused
on with these three in particular is
making their movements really cute when
they're represented in the game like for
example in battle and other parts in the
game you see them moving around and
they're really cute kind of make you
want to reach out and touch them
almost
and another thing we always pay
attention to with or really focus on
with the initial Pokemon that you choose
for your partner is uh making them kind
of universally relatable so people from
around the world will be able to look at
these Pokemon and relate with them very
easily and also very easy to understand
like for example the grass type Pokemon
is going to be green obviously so being
careful with the colors I think what
folks have seen already from the
animations that we've shown in a little
bit of video footage we've been able to
share they they have a lot of
Personality um I actually picked Papo
because I'm a hardcore water starter fan
my first was a squirtle and I've stuck
with them but I've been having a great
time so far and I I'm I'm looking
forward to seeing what other folks pick
when they get into the starters as
well it's interesting actually what you
talked about with the the design of the
starter Pokemon and I think they also
really fit nicely in with the kind of
tropical climate and environment we've
got and I know that's something that you
worked in with the design of the player
characters as well this time
around
so yeah obviously the region this time
the climate there is extremely warm so
we wanted to make sure that the uh
characters the designs were more lightly
dressed than they maybe other designs
have in the past I think fans will
notice the proportions are different
especially we get into gameplay in a
couple seconds here um they're going to
see it's it's it's a little different
how they're used to seeing their
characters in the
game so yeah we uh we changed the
proportions this time to be more
realistic we really want to kind of
increase this sense of immersion and I
think you'll see that when we get into
the game yeah I I don't know if I can
talk about this yet but sharpy viewers
probably noticed that both of those uh
pieces of art there was an interesting
break bracelet that the players were
wearing I don't know if we can probably
can't talk about that just
[Laughter]
yet for later time maybe we can talk
about that um but I think we' probably
kept folks in anticipation long enough
so Terry you want to jump in and show us
some gameplay I'm excited for
this so just want to mention as we get
into gameplay here this game is still in
development so uh folks uh everything
you see here might not be exactly what
you're going to see in the final release
of the game but I think we can give you
a really good sense of what the game is
going to look and feel like as we get
[Music]
started this is actually the first time
for us uh to show a Pokémon game at this
stage in development kind of via live
gameplay so uh not really sure exactly
what we're going to encounter in this we
may see some all new Pokemon that
haven't been revealed before Oh keep my
fingers across that would be really cool
um actually as we get started here uh M
morisan can you tell us a little bit
about uh the story and the background of
what's going on right now in the
game
so at this point in the game it's a
little bit uh slightly into it but it's
uh the player actually had just moved to
the alola region uh the other day and uh
one day previous to where we are in the
game he received his first partner
Pokemon for his adventure and right now
we're actually on the way to a
neighboring town where there's a a
festival oh and I think here we can see
what we were talking about earlier oh
you're just jumping into the long
ground
so as you can see in the alola region
obviously it's not just new Pokemon that
are unique to the region but from other
regions you see
Pokemon here in battle you see the
trainer is actually standing behind uh
the Poke the Pokémon uh in the battle so
we really wanted to express this uh
feeling of the trainer always being with
his or her Pokémon yeah I'd love to talk
about that in a little bit more detail
here because I feel like there's so much
that you've done with um uh the way the
battle looks in this game to make it
feel really intense and really immersive
I was wondering if we could talk a
little bit more about that with what you
did with um the lighting and the dynamic
camera angles
here
so yeah there's some cool lighting uh
effects that we're doing here where for
example like the shadow you see it's uh
in the evening right now so it's a bit
longer but depending on the time of day
the the lighting will kind of affect the
mood of the
battle I think here Terry's kind of
staying still for a second to let us see
how the camera is is moving around and
this is something that'll just happen
for you if you're staying still in the
battle for a moment and you really get a
good chance to get a look at these
Pokemon and the area that you're in and
the
environment so yeah there's definitely
some cool uh we tried to make the camera
feel really D dynamic in the battles
this time around and actually as uh
Terry gets started in the battle here I
was wonder if we could talk a little bit
more about uh the different changes you
made the battle interface I know there's
a lot here that's really interesting
which makes the game really accessible
to new players maybe this is their first
Pokémon game but it's also I think
really satisfying as someone who's
played a lot of Pokemon games it just it
feels really good the changes that
you've made
[Music]
here
so for example yeah we really tried to
focus on making it really accessible and
easy to understand uh you saw in the
moves there Terry just pressed the
little eye button or the icon that's on
the move and you can go into a detailed
explanation of what that move actually
does I think it's been so helpful there
there just so many Pokemon that you have
to to keep in mind now as you're
battling it's so nice to be able to pull
it up and if maybe you don't quite
remember what something does being able
to pop it up really fast there it's like
you don't have to use that information
but if maybe your remember it's not as
good as it used to be and you need it
it's so nice to be able to pull that up
and take a
look tap
on so actually you can see there's the
you can tap on the 2D Pokemon icon
that's up the touch screen and see how
its parameters actually just got changed
um because of the effect of and of of a
move so as you just said like a lot of
things you had to keep in your head you
had to remember uh before now visualize
on the interface
itself all right let's see how this
battle goes are are you planning on
trying to capture I'm going to begin my
quest to catch them all okay good
[Laughter]
Lu yeah you can do it I think so um just
to to bring up real quickly for folks
who maybe haven't played a Pokemon game
before um battling Pokémon is really at
the core of what the series is all about
you're going out into the world with
your Pokémon battling oh this is the
most stressful
moment okay we're able to catch this
Pokemon um but it's a really interesting
game if you're interested in battle and
strategy and uh collecting all these
really interesting Pokemon that you
meet oh popo leveled up good job Y and
it was nice there too seeing how the the
level up change they up and the so
oh and this is actually something that
we should talk about as well um can you
tell our viewers a little bit more about
um what they're seeing on the upper
screen
here
so one of the things we wanted to do
with the Pokédex this time was really
encourage players to again really want
to catch them all really fill up the
Pokédex and one way we've done that you
can see there's the ladyb just got
registered but next to it is a white
Pokeball icon and what that does that
indicates there's an empty space which
means that either it has an evolution or
maybe there's another Pokemon out there
that kind of forms a pair with it so
that'll kind of encourage players to
really want to fill up that empty space
go out and search and you know catch all
different types of Pokemon and kind of
complete their Pokédex yeah it's
especially exciting I think when you
find one and there's lots of white
Pokeballs and you're just like okay so a
lot we
got nice one of the new
ones
so as you can see this is the P new
Pokemon called young goose um it's
always hungry so it's always uh getting
hungry and then so it's looking for food
but whenever it's hungry it also gets
very aggressive I love its
[Laughter]
face I feel kind of bad for it though I
feel like we just throw in a bag of
chips or something and it be
[Laughter]
like oh
getting close
there you probably able to catch this
one run our away oh good luck that's two
down yeah this is always like the most
stressful seconds in any Pokemon
player's life just
the and actually this will give us a
chance to maybe take a look at the
Pokédex we got a new Pokemon to check
out oh
so we've got some uh some interesting
changes coming to the Pokedex in this
game um can you tell us a little bit
more about what fans can expect from the
new
poke
so actually one of the new uh things in
this game is that we have this uh item
called the RM Pokédex and RM kind of
inhabits your Pokédex and actually helps
you uh in your adventure so it'll tell
you information about uh Pokemon that
you really want to catch or uh give you
tips about how to catch Pokemon and also
kind of guide you on your adventure
where you should go next for example so
it serves as a really cool supportive
function so right here actually we're
we're still really early in the game we
don't have the RM Pokédex so the touch
screen is just black on the bottom but
you'll get it later
and here actually this is a great chance
if we just like take a little quick
circle around we can show off uh not
only the trainer's proportions but also
the the movement is a little bit
different than what folks played
previous Pokemon games have
expected so yeah you can move around
free uh full analog movement this time
in the game oh oh we need to tell
players what's going on here when
they're seeing the The Shadow
so you see that uh lady over there or
the girl throwing a Pokeball up and down
and uh so she's a Pokemon trainer and
what uh she's obviously going to try and
battle you but what that kind of uh
shadow that appears in the screen
indicates is that there's a that she's
going to challenge you to a battle so it
kind of increases this sense of tension
of you're going about to go into a
battle that indicates that to the player
so I can either avoid her or actually
battle
her I think we battle it feels like that
moment where two people are glaring at
each
other to
fight but it is really nice if you're in
a position where maybe you're trying to
get somewhere really quickly or your
Pokemon aren't in great shape right now
you don't want to fight it's it's nice
to have that second where you can avoid
it before you just kind of stumble
yourself into a
battle
yeah that's right I think so we can see
here um we're seeing the other trainer
as well and it's really nice actually
just to get such a good look at the
Pokemon proportions alongside their
trainers yeah that's definitely one of
the new things I think by having the
trainers in battle like you mentioned it
really gives you that sense of scale I
think from the experience I've had at
the office playing this game it's really
going to surprise people when they take
a look at just how big and small certain
Pokemon are when they're actually
standing right next to
them
and with the trainers being represented
in full 3d this time they all have
unique uh motions and reactions for
example how they throw their Pokeball or
their reaction when they lose for
example so you just got an item
there I think there might be some more
folks we can battle up
here as we're walking around I'm hoping
folks who are watching or listening with
the volume up so they can hear the the
music in this area I just I found it
really great how it feels uh it really
fits in with the tropical
[Music]
environment I love how enthusiastic you
look all right
Oliver another goose looks
like and we can see as Terry's battling
here um with how the battle interface is
set up it's really easy to just get
super involved in the battle to to
whatever extent you want to be um you've
got all this information at your
fingertips it's not that you have to
look at it all but it's so nice that if
there's anything that you need to check
on you can do it so quickly and and you
still feel really immersed in the
battle
so yeah of course it really there's a
lot of depth to the battles but you
don't have for example beginners for
example maybe don't want to or they
won't remember a lot of these uh
different status changes and whatnot but
you can really quickly check on the the
state and see how things have changed I
say I I love young Goose's painting
animation
so
cute so this a pick a pack it's called
the wood poker or excuse me the wood
wood po I can't even speak but so the
the setting of this Pokemon is that it
can actually PE 16 times in 1 second so
it's got very fast uh beat
very particular about the number
16 that's yeah watching its animation as
it's it's got very birdlike movements as
it's kind of twitching its head side to
side and I think that the level of
detail that you guys have put into all
the Pokemon animations in this game is
really
fantastic oh no no oh oh oh no
oh hopefully one of your new friends is
ready to help us
out as a good chance to mention actually
uh we did find a Pokéball earlier as
we're walking around and you can find
items to help you out along the way that
can help you heal up your Pokemon
and
[Laughter]
risk
we almost got wiped out there good
that's high RIS to catch them
all oh your your ladyb got a level out
of that though
M almost another
one this is definitely one of the I
think one of the things that really
makes Pokemon a fun game is kind of like
the sense of tension
here so do we have anything we can give
poota I think it's time to go to
Festival oh
ready oh no we'll just run for this one
all
right ter are you going to heal up after
this yeah we'll get healed up we'll get
healed up I think get to the festival
cuz that's not to give too much away but
there's there's more fighting in your
future more fighting
so uh actually as we come into the this
area here we're going to be meeting
several different characters that our
viewers maybe aren't familiar with uh
would you mind just giving us a quick
introduction to
them so this is hollow I think it's been
red revealed already in a video that
we've released but uh it's really strong
trainer on this island and he's actually
the uh guy who gives you your first uh
partner Pokemon in your
adventure a very strong trainer on this
[Music]
island so this is how and you're about
to battle him actually as part of this
[Music]
festival and that's Professor cui right
there in the white lab code he's a
professor who specializes in researching
Pokemon moves like their attacks and
such yeah I think based on the fan
response I've seen he is quickly
becoming the most dreamy Professor thank
you for
the
and that's uh Lily behind you there
she's the assistant of Professor Ki and
she's not a Pokemon trainer but she'll
join you on your adventure throughout
the story and sharp viewers may have
noticed that bag is kind of
interesting there something there
yeah
[Laughter]
unfortunately you saw it
move I think it's time we go into the
festival
battle I think it's going to be really
interesting for fans of the series to
see this battle and and the space uh the
way that Pokemon and Pokemon battles are
integrated into the culture in these
islands is really interesting and you
get these amazing battle spaces where
other folks are gathering around and and
watching you guys fight
so in this uh in this particular
Festival actually this is kind of a a
cele or a way to kind of kick off both
you and how's Adventures to kind of
travel across the island so it's kind of
a ritual in this
society and uh folks may have noticed
there was a another thing where we can't
really talk about too much but just to
mention tapa
Coco worth paying attention to that
name more information can't really talk
too much about it uh so how brought out
a Pichu
looks
adorable leave it to
me and here we can see see what he's
done for checking different
[Music]
effects you see both your status changes
as well as the opponent status changes
to really see what's going on in the
battle so looking at this tropical
environment I'm really hoping that you
guys were able to pull off some business
trips to some nice tropical locations
maybe I mean it's for research it's work
just have to
[Music]
go
so yeah we actually took uh as the the
staff the development staff at gameer we
took trips to Hawaii to really do some
research and we' definitely utilize that
to kind of reflect in the game and I
should have convinced my boss that I
need to do that cut for this to to
really get this segment I I really need
to
[Laughter]
gow come on Terry show what you
got so we start with the icons of the
battle started um I think how has one
more Pokemon to
go oh had a new skill
nice
[Music]
stronger there we see one of the other
new
[Music]
starters
so at this point in the story you see uh
how has L uh which is another one of the
first Pokemon you can choose in your
adventure but you've actually
encountered uh you've battled against
him and his liten once in the story and
so once you've in Pokemon Sun and Moon
once you've battled a Pokemon once the
next time you battle it you'll get
information on your move list about
which moves are effective and which ones
aren't
I'm not so just explaining that you know
is
superti with
that so just coming back to make it all
very easy to understand for even
beginners of the games yeah it really is
so nice to have that
information I think especially when
you're trying to catch more Pokemon
you're like okay I I actually maybe
don't want to be super effective right
now I need to kind of whle this Pokemon
down so being able to remember maybe you
want to use your weaker attack sometimes
just kind of get just to that
point job then I love what a good sport
to is about losing to he's just kind of
it's all
good so I don't think we can go too much
further in the gameplay because we're
going to start giving away story
elements that we don't want to show
folks yet um but you did bring another
video for us to take a look at that has
um a new gameplay mode that I don't
think folks seen
[Music]
before
so with uh the Pokemon series obviously
uh communic using it as a kind of a
communication tool facilitating that
communication between players has always
been one of the things we've really
focused on with the game so trading and
battling between players of course U
this time that's no different we've got
an all new multiplayer battle mode which
we're calling the uh Battle Royale all
right well let's see if our crew can
load that up for us and we can uh check
out
[Music]
theed so as we get started here can you
tell us a little bit about what the
rules are for Battle Royale and how the
matches are
[Music]
decided so in this mode it's actually
four players um each player chooses up
to three Pokemon and battles with one at
a time um in this video here we're just
uh doing one Pokemon for the sake of
time
so how this actually works with uh how
it determines the winner so this is a
free-for-all battle um but whenever one
of the trainers when the first trainer
to lose uh all of his or her Pokemon
that signals the end of the
battle and then once the battle is over
once the first person loses all their
Pokemon
uh then the to determine the winner the
game tallies up each players how many
Pokemon they've defeated and also how
many Pokemon they have remaining on
their team and whoever has the highest
number is the winner of the Battle
Royale I think it's really interesting
what this is going to do for strategy as
folks are playing because generally
speaking when you're thinking about how
you're going to switch up your Pokemon
to fight another trainer uh it's only a
one-on-one situation so you can look at
their Pokemon and say okay I've got this
Pokemon that's going to be strong
against this one but you're worried
about two other opponents here so you
really have to think about who's going
to Fair best against
three
opponents so yeah it's a freefor all and
of course you know you could have three
people gang up on one really strong
person or you really have to kind of
determine your strategy about how you're
going to you know which order you're
going to defeat Pokemon who you're going
to focus on so totally new uh gameplay D
yeah it is interesting how how much more
intense it feels where I'm used to just
looking at the trainer in front of me
and fighting them and suddenly it's like
oh it's two more trainers they have to
pay attention to
everybody and folks watching there you
may have caught that the trainers there
were wearing different outfits from what
we saw with the uh the regular player
characters that we've shown off so far
we can't really talk about that yet but
worth
noticing got a good ey
there so yeah you can actually customize
your outfits in in this game as well so
so we're just about out of time but
before we wrap up um I was curious now
that you've had a chance to uh see some
fan reaction for these games um how's it
been seeing how uh Pokemon fans have
reacted for Pokemon Sun and Pokemon
Moon
pokon
so
so yes the F the reaction from everyone
has been really great you know I get
tons of messages and tweets and
everything uh this being the you know
the 20th anniversary of Pokemon uh one
of the goals we really want to kind of
you know for the future of Pokemon
really kind of expand it to even a wider
audience and as I think you we've
announced previously uh in addition to
the seven languages we had in X and Y
and Omega Ruby Alpha Sapphire we also
added Chinese simplified Chinese and
traditional Chinese and I think a lot of
the especially from those regions like
fans have really been kind of excited
about it and sending me lots of great
messages and uh is there anything uh
final that you'd like to wrap up and say
to fans who are watching the stream
right
now so yeah I think sun and moon we're
really doing a lot of new challenges for
for us here's game freak so I hope
everyone really look forward to the
games thank
you
so there was a lot of challenges for me
especially as it's the first time
directing in you an entirely new
generation of Pokemon at game freak but
I think we've really uh brought the game
together it's really turned into
something fantastic and I hope fans
really look forward to it I I know I'm
definitely looking forward to it and
thank you so much uh for joining us and
giving us some insight into the
development work here uh folks watching
again that was Pokemon Sun and Pokemon
Moon which are coming out for the
Nintendo 3DS family of systems this
November so you don't have to wait too
much longer and uh please don't go
anywhere in a few moments we're actually
going to be coming back uh anuman is
going to be stopping by to show us some
gameplay for a game you might be
thinking about Legend of Zelda breath of
the wild so uh please don't go anywhere
we'll be right back thank
you
[Music]
joined us here um we're going to talk a
little bit about uh a little game here
that I think a lot of people are excited
about the Legend of Zelda breath of the
wild uh before we jump right into things
though uh Mr auma I think uh is there
anything a message you have to the
fans
of so I've created this game thinking
about breaking the conventions of Zelda
and I know that a lot of fans have seen
the trailer and they probably want us to
jump right in so why don't we get
started let's do
it we're going to be showing a lot of
The Legend of Zelda today starting right
here we're going to show you what you
can do and we're going to introduce you
to this amazing world but we're going to
try not to spoil anything so feel free
to tune in for as long as you
like
Open Your
Eyes Open Your
Eyes
wake up
[Music]
link
this is a very mysterious Place Al
Numan I've talked about breaking the
conventions of zeldas but uh link does
start by waking
up keep that rooted in the
tradition
this really is a mysterious place and
it's kind of very
[Music]
um that is a sheika slate
take it it will help guide you after
your long
Slumber so here we see the introduction
of a very mysterious
item so in the past series we've used
Wars and Magic but um this time around
we introduced
technology
I know a lot of people are going to be
so excited to see how that plays out in
this game because that's such
a a a great new wrinkle to add to to the
Zelda
franchise and um he's going to start
with by opening the treasure
box um these are clothing items that um
he can
wear link was um pretty much
[Music]
naked bill you can actually play this
nude too if you want not quite my
style that would also make you very
vulnerable to enemies just so you
know we'll show you the
way
and so we see here one of the
functionalities of the shika slate is
activating this
pedestal and opening this door
here so it
starts
link you are the
light our light that must shine upon
highy rule once
again now
go so as you can see on the screen it
says jump Now link can jump for the
first
time and um the jump is for him to climb
up the
[Music]
wall now we see the subtitle on screen
perhaps this would be a good time for
Aluma I on to talk about that a little
bit
so in the previous titles we used
character names and item names as
subtitles but this time around we wanted
to
um uh wanted to um showcase the world of
Zelda and I think especially from that
that sweeping panoramic shot right there
we see how much how much of a character
the world is how much of a presence the
the world is in this and I know hearing
some of the iterations of of
possibilities for uh for the subtitle
and um you know I remember the moment
when I first heard breath of the wild
and it was just like oh that's it that's
the right one it just it felt so right
with this the in tune with with the
nature and and the sort of expansiveness
of this
world
so link can climbed the mountain or the
wall just like you said you saw
here so that is the green uh you see the
Green Gauge on the left um that's the
stamina gauge and you can kind of see
how much he can climb by that gauge
and then there's a lot of items
scattered all around the world and you
can take those um you can pick those
up and then um as a Nintendo we of
course have to have this here mushrooms
we love our
mushrooms and this mushroom is not going
to make link any
bigger good to know
so as you can see Lincoln push off big
rocks down the hill um he can use all
these little items and elements and um
incorporate it into gameplay
MH see already Bill doing some Gathering
a lot of climbing here already there's
this sense of you're just thrown into
this world of exploration right off the
bat for the point on the map
[Music]
slate somebody's calling you
Bill so here we get our first look at
the map uh this circular area here being
uh the extent of the E3 demo that we're
showing this is a a high plateau in the
center of Hyrule uh um we'll give you
just a sneak peek of uh how big that is
but I think you'll get to see a better
look at the scale of the world uh later
on
today no I got a baked
apple oh no you took a baked apple he
scolded you oh now who who is this
gentleman Mr Ana would you like to share
with
people he's kind of mysterious
[Music]
looking and in the first of the series I
think you met a guy like
this he says this is the great plateau
and he describes it as the birthplace of
the kingdom of
Hyrule
so you can see the temple that's very um
worn
down yes he says the kingdom is in a
state of
decay so I picked up a tree branch
earlier uh currently it's all I have for
a a weapon uh but you can see very
quickly uh the things that I can do with
a tree
branch and I
can you can do a lot of things but you
can just set everything on
fire I think we've just seen a window
into Bill's play
style
uh I picked up an
Axe and so I can
also swap my weapons out so I'll switch
over to the axxe uh the axe is great cuz
I
can chop down trees if I want to get to
some
apples use all the resources right I can
even chop the logs that I've cut to get
firewood uh which I can later use to set
a
campfire so it's very nice neatly
bundled up already for you it's amazing
convenient yeah I think honestly first
time I got my hands on the real I spent
the first 20 minutes like chopping down
trees and climbing trees that's that's
all I
did I've always been a big fan of the
Coro
so these guys are actually hiding
everywhere in the world
here oh what do we have there it I miss
on looks like I've already come across
the master
sword maybe you found
it ah did you get it already did you
find
it
oh
[Laughter]
sorry there's no way I'm going to play
something that important
here that would be the ultimate in
Breaking with the Zelda
conventions now I do need a shield so I
think I'm going to run up this way as
you can see the the world is open to me
I can go any direction that I want um
but I'm going to run up here through the
grass uh I've have a sword so perhaps I
should cut some
grass but nothing's coming
out so I guess you want to know how link
can um get
life getting damage so let's try
fighting some of these
enemies
stumbl down to a cobbling camp
[Music]
here well he going to dispatch them with
some extreme prejudice here I
think there we go it's it's not much of
a shield but I've got a pot lid
get
uhoh
oh he's taunting me oh no I'm going to
need some health here in a
[Music]
bit
no and your sword broke
so oh your Shield broke oh I stole his
spear so um for this title the weapons
that link have actually will break as he
used
them so um the cycle of this game is
that you get go into a battle with
enemies and then you take their weapons
and then so you can use them as your
own so perhaps we'll head down and check
out some of these
ruins oh
oh you have your your heart's getting a
little lower
bill so let's see
how so you can see that little heart
icon um on
the and it shows that you can get um
half of the heart back if you
it
so this time around you're not going to
find any hearts in the grass um but
you're going to be eating these um food
items and you can get your energy
stamina back up using that way to
replenish your health there's I love I
love that notion of really having to
take advantage of the resources in the
world with also with grabbing the
weapons we were talking about you know
you're getting those from enemies you're
you're finding them in certain places
and then using using the food as this
resource to keep to keep your health up
is also really interesting it's a lot of
[Music]
fun so it's almost like a survival game
where you have to get all the collect
all these items so you can move on with
the
game
so bill here is executing the flurry
rush so when you um match when you get a
perfect timing um the enemy slows down
and then it's easier for you to attack
the enemies looks like I got a new pair
of trousers which I've been needing to
pick up so
uh okay you can see that there's quite a
lot to to look around at and discover in
the world going to run past those
barrels
[Music]
there we don't have a good idea of
what's going on in Hyrule here but but
uh everything seems to be in
ruin so you saw these guys in the
trailer they're
Guardians and they're enemies but as you
can see these guys are not moving
anymore
so there must be some sort of a time
lapse
mhm so I know a lot of people are going
to be really excited about how you're
dropped into this world and there's you
know minimal backstory there's not
there's not a lot upfront in this game
other than here you are what are you
going to do what do you want to do where
do you want to go and then yet there's
so many hints in this environment about
that H something greater has happened
and I think uh people will be really
interested to see the story sort of
unfold uh as they play the
game
so I think with this title you'll be
able to learn these Back stories like
you said Ed that um you'll be able to
learn them little by little on your own
pace it's not that the game is telling
you but you can kind of explore and find
out on your own M this might also be a
good time to talk a little bit about the
art style and uh and just the nature of
the game itself the if you if you look
at link and and the world it's clearly
deeply inspired ired by Japanese
animation
so um we've used this tune like style
before in the previous title but um in
order for the players to see an item to
find an item it's actually easier to um
to use the animation style where you
create something and then you shave off
off the elements so the items will be
the users will be able to identify the
items easier rather than adding on
elements so to the
background so the same here is not that
we wanted to create um an animation
Style game but um
we wanted to um to use this art style
and match it to the functions of this
game and you see here um the time limit
on the demo that people will have access
to on the show floor we were supposed to
disable that that was uh that was my
mistake that's all right that's all
right what we can do is we'll uh we'll
skip through a few
things it's an organic playthrough it's
true to the nature of the game
itself
so yeah this is something that the users
will experience tonight on the show
floor
so and I think people saw you know that
that actually gives people at home a
sense of how much time people are going
to have here um and as Reggie said
nobody's going to be able to explore
even just this small area that we're
showing here at E3 and that's that that
speaks to just how large this experience
is going to be and I think people are
going to be really excited to just just
get that little taste a
[Music]
bit but uh in in going back and and
talking about the art style um the the
colors are very reminiscent of a type of
paint called gouache um and gouache was
actually uh it's it's a material that is
used frequently in uh in animation um
but it's also a material that's used in
a style of painting uh that is called a
or uh in in English open air painting
where you you go out into the
environment and you sit down in front of
the uh the object that you intend to
paint and you paint it in that real
world setting um and then you know as we
started looking at uh you know the art
style and its its similarities to
gouache and and that connection we also
started to feel that uh the music in the
game also has a very open a feeling to
it isn't that correct
Donan
so because the uh the players will be
able to explore and do anything that
they want to we couldn't use the
conventional um types of music where we
know that where the users would go and
we can kind of um get the music uh more
dynamic as um the users explore certain
areas of the map so this time around we
kind of took a different
approach so um as you can hear um
there's a lot of environmental sounds um
that you hear throughout the game and
then we um we try to um blend that music
that sound into the game as much as we
can and then you can hear a little piano
sounds of piano throughout the game I
think and then the sounds of piano
actually matches this um nature element
very
well should be and then the sounds of
piano actually um kind of strikes a
chord in people's emotions too so I
think it works really
well so when um when you're playing the
game and when link goes through
something and then if that piano sound
happens to come on it kind of um it
makes you feel so emotional just hearing
that perfect match of the movement and
the
music so the music is um Our intention
was to because this game it has 100 ways
of playing it if there is a 100 players
playing it so we kind of wanted to make
that um that very unique experience for
every
player
I know longtime fans of the series
that's going to be one of the first
things they notice you know there's not
the constant theme music always always
present everywhere you go and uh this
this new take on the sort of on the AAL
experience is really it's really
refreshing it's true to the game and it
it is it does resonate it's it feels
really good to
play
yeah I'm really happy to hear that
Ed Bill continuing go campaign of
brutality yes I forgot to sorry I forgot
to put my pants
on just like any other day so we do have
uh you know one of the things that we're
not showing in this morning segment
that's going to be coming up uh in just
a little bit is uh puzzle solving um
you'll be seeing some of that today
you'll be seeing quite a bit of
exploration and the ways to use uh the
objects that you've discovered um but
one of the things you know there's a lot
of different ways that you can kind of
experiment with the the environment uh
and the world here in breath of the wild
so I'm just going to have uh a little
bit of fun uh with a little little
project I I want to try out
here oh oh oh oh okay well I like that
you call this setup a project
Bill let's
see I don't know what you're trying to
do here bill
uh let's see if it's close enough
NOP
oh get another club let's see if we can
make that
happen oh no not
quite maybe I have an idea
here oh hey you live I did I
survived at your heart bill that was
quite uh quite dangerous thank you for
joining us for Bill we have a little
yeah we have a little bit of news uh I
think everybody has been uh excited uh
for some special Zelda items coming to
Momo uh We've we've just been told that
those items will be going live at 300
p.m. Pacific time so be sure to check in
to me Tomo today to get your free Zelda
themed items there um we have a lot more
Zelda coming
as we as we've talked about we're really
focusing on introducing you to the world
the things you can do in the world um
how you're going to be surviving uh it's
really all about the actions and the
activities M you won't be seeing so much
in terms of characters and story so if
you're the type of person who doesn't
want to be spoiled feel free to tune in
all day
yeah
there's so much more I want to tell you
about this game so please look forward
to it yes so stay tuned um we're going
to take another look at our next segment
we're going to be focused on some
exploration so uh thank you noro mruma
thank you Bill thank you very much for
your time and uh don't go anywhere we
got more Legend of Zelda breath of the
wild coming
[Music]
up
do
[Music]
n
d
[Music]
you
n
[Music]
when I see the
sun it's
all when I see the
moon
rise it's all
right
everything is changing my
senses
[Music]
you the journe be making the time we are
Tak so
much to
do it's all
right
[Music]
and it's
all well it's
[Music]
all and it's all
right
[Music]
he
everything is all
[Applause]
[Music]
right everything
is
[Music]